[Musique]
ils iront du jeu plein de la vie si tous
kankan est astucieux
johnny s'explique sur le plus sérieux
[Musique]
savait pas jouer il suffit de vouloir
revenir à un ami
tu te dois fait ne fait pas ça dessus
pour être fermé j'ai dû changer de
regard des suspects si tout est en train
d'essayer de me prendre ma fille celle à
as tu te faut pas faire chaque kit ou
les bâtis to help it où je suis après
s'être fait officiel
il faut pas tirer ceux qui soutiennent
non alors voilà ce que nous allons faire
mais bonjour à tous et à toutes faut
dire bonjour bonjour à tous et à toutes
nous avons une ficelle comment faire un
noeud en prenant les deux bouts de la
ficelle sans les lâcher alors vous
pouvez vous pouvez essayer comme ça ça
va pas ouvrir
c'est pas moi tentez une affaire comme
ça ça va pas ça vous ne pouvez pas
l'astuce consiste tout simplement à vous
croisez les bras et attraper un morceau
de la ficelle à droite
et puis l'autre comme ceci et puis alors
maintenant si vous tirez hop vous avez
obtenu un véritable noeud voilà oui a
retrouvé sa tito a été très très
américain c'est rigolo st
mais alors à dix mois effectué peut le
défaire de la même façon on sort 100
mètres laissant lâché sans lâcher les
noms ça je ne peux pas je ne vois pas ce
sera pour une autre fois ce droit ça je
ne lis pas je ne vais pas répéter valeur
on va la campagne alors aux moteurs à
williams a au moins tabous pousse moussu
est belle oui oui ils savaient pas enfin
le mode amaury oui c'est un jeu qui
consiste à regarder très attentivement
des cartons sur lesquels se trouvent des
dessins les cinq équipes forment des
syllabes et à partir de ces six là vous
former des mots voilà les choses seront
difficiles à faire et il faut se
concentrer il faut que bell en face m
parce que belle belle emma n'a jamais
fait
une fois je suis arrivé quand même
jamais et moi qui en faisait un jour
elle me ryan
il s'est trouvé mon mauvais mais amusant
alors bon ça fait 5 cartons comme
d'habitude mais elle est encore jeune
dans le dans le jeu je connais jean
prend 5
oui 5 1 2 alors attend peut-être les
bombes comme ça 1 à 2 3 pierre boulle du
yen bon alors 1 2 et 9 3 4
qu'est ce que c'est que tout ça
qu'est-ce que ça non savoura and haas là
c'est un vent un bon oui et oui mais là
c'est quoi la cité des oliviers des
oeufs
ici c'est le bout de la ligne abbas à sa
nouvelle situation
ainsi le slovaque jiri la mta alors
maintenant ben moi j'en ai un bon mois
j'en ai un
ah ben moi moi moi moi aussi je crois
que j'en ai trouvé un c'est vrai ah oui
alors je t'écoute dont je croyais non à
nyon a jamais trouvées en asie
brick en boule de croix de thé partira
mardi toujours y toujours latente
n'attente tantôt lyrique oui quand la
caf
oui il est l'option tentation à
troisvaux bravo puis comme on sait quand
on maîtrise assez bien joué un an quand
on est content alors tant tation voilée
mais si c'est bien joué une faute on a
été obligés de tirer d'autres cartons et
parce que avec il ne réglait pas ici
pour pouvoir faire un mot alors nous
avons un étai en plus on à l'ars a alors
là bien faire avec ça en moi j'en ai un
monsois il est pas extraordinaire mais
giteau et moi tu as trouvé toi oui anne
on ne le savait pas non parce que je
pensais à invention melcion et prix déjà
oui c'est dommage on aurait pu le
reprendre marque encore une fois ma mère
en est un autre bel oui on annonce y en
a un autre qu'est ce que tu vas y toi un
vent et r inventaire inventaire mais
nous ayons jamais sur la voie a battu
m'a mis sur la voie mais quand mais bon
ça c'est bien joué
tu voulais utiliser mention alors un
inventaire
oui les yeux quoi un inventaire didon
c'est bien ça arrive tu vois tu veux à
temps nous allons faire un vent terre
ah oui ça s'écrit pas comme la terre
arles avignon avec lui voilà inventaire
barre
effectivement c'est bien ça 1,3 xinhua
qu'il allait bien c'est parfait bien
joué félicitations on va pouvoir
regarder on va pouvoir regarder les
dessins de nos petits amis
pourquoi pas les on y va aussi je fais
le mort à boules qui va tirer le cpie
quand vous vous attend nous avons trop
ça m'a l'air formidable ça attends
attends c'est une lettre qui nous vient
de youcam à séoul et quel endroit
as tu en as tu attends je m'appelle you
are you came et 11 ans
c'est son look à milan 11 ans maman
s'appelle quimby oulémas voilà les
enfants nous a fait un dessin je vous le
montrer et battraient bien au regard des
gras et très regardé ça si c'est beau
prêt de titres et de cette admirable ça
mais bon alors il y en a un autre jeu la
pression aumessas à ses très jolies à
pouss moussu là où je le reconnais dit
au micro son joli ils sont beaux bravo
alors vous avez vraiment agréé doit
frapper fort très bien leila méritait
donc hauteur de recevoir le 10 508
certainement ils l'ont bien mérité des
quatre amis vous le recevrez très
bientôt vous pourrez chanter avec nous
bon là qu'est fait à nous maintenant eh
ben c'est à nous à nous alors à nous
pour le jeu de push moussu pour le jeu
ah oui tu as ton marqueur isolables au
très bien alors un mot en huile est à
huy huile est mais je crois que tu vas
trouver parce que je suis là il est
facile tu vas voir oui et alors ça
commence par un b 1b
et oui en huile est alors touché les
petits traits comme d'habitude soit 25,6
et la dernière 1 e
ah voilà alors ça se mange
ah bah oui jasmin vu ça je n'en mange
pas tous les jours ben enfin sa semence
avait au début du repas
mais oui on peut reprendre au début du
ramadan alors qu en 2010 est ce que
c'est un légume
oui c'est un légume c'est un légume très
sévère
je sais ça a dit je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs c'est plutôt rouge à ça a des
fans verte c'est rouge c'est plutôt
rouge oui en entrevue à la campagne dans
les champs donne moi une autre lettre
alors une autre lettre la troisième
oui un t1 t3 la wii faut faire ait fait
ce grand combien de lettres a tout dit
et bah j'ai dû l'être
huit lettres wii wheel est oui et tu
penserais peut-être à betteraves
betteraves tu vois qu'il a trouvé
facilement les travaux ont été faits
entre humains les cris comment
betteraves et bbb ter à v e
ben oui ah ben moi je le crois tu que ça
s'écrirait plutôt comme ça encore encore
une faute d'orthographe j'en ai pas il
ya deux temps
voilà ah bah oui mais alors comment veux
tu que je retrouve avril et moins que
j'ai mis à insulter parce que c'est bête
et bah oui moi j'écoute cet écrivain
comme le co2 et baisse
m
là tu sais ce que je trouve drôle dans
avec les betteraves
ouais bah c'est qu'elles sont rouges à
l'intérieur c'est avec ça qu'on fait du
sucre c'est pourquoi ces amusantes
ces travaux restent route ça très
amusant bon eh bah écoute à série nous
allons retrouver belle hein oui nous
sommes d'accord c'est pas si la musique
tu verras tu vois comment va ta marins
ne bêle bêle as-tu de nouvelles bienne à
téléphonique à hyères le yen m'a dit
qu'elle allait très bien au procès se
promènent aller sur un bateau elle vogue
sur la mer qu'elle pense beaucoup à bas
ces gens là qu'est ce qu'on écoute
aujourd'hui alors un instrument de
musique
après je fais quand même pas te dire le
caire n'ont pu mais d'abord appuyé sur
le petit bouton de ma petite boîte
wima de fini j'écoute
[Musique]
oui oui qu'est-ce que ça ça c'est une
clarinette exact c'est une clarinette
c'est un bois c'est un bel instrument on
utilise beaucoup dans le jazz nouvelle
orléans
et puis on l'utilisé aussi en musique
classique oui c'est vrai bon j'adore le
jazz à moi aussi j'adore ça j'en ai joué
moi de la clarinette en jazz dans des
orchestres d'étudiants oui on pourrait
peut-être écouter un petit peu de
classique et puis ensuite si tu veux je
serai de souffler dans une clarinette
oui oui pas mal non plus de gaulle à sic
on écoute
oui c'est pierre et le loup
[Musique]
tha
oui oui effectivement je crois que la
clarinette interprète le rôle du chat
c'est une très très belle histoire
oui absolument alors j'ai j'ai une
clarinette là va voir es-tu si oui ben
je savais un peu tu vas pouvoir mais je
veux quelque chose qui chouine gh je
vais essayer les tice et je crois que
c'est une clarinette qui a beaucoup
souffert
elle a vécu oui oui elle a vécu qui est
elle était peut-être un petit peu
fatigué mans ça on doit pouvoir quand
même se débrouiller je vais essayer on
verra bien ce que ça nous décrit ali
quelque chose qui chauffe un petit prix
voilà elle a des baous évidemment elle
est passée sous un bulldozer alors ça ne
les arrange pas totalement sommes encore
à partir demande si c'est vraiment de la
food à la clarinette
[Applaudissements]
tu vois ça un petit peu
dis donc je me fatigue et moi ah la la
oh
waouh fatigué maintenant je sais pas si
j'ai encore du souffle pour chanter tu
te rends compte
ça va être difficile mais enfin on va se
reprendre et puis une clarinette ce qui
est formidable c'est que ce n'est pas
grâce à ceux des mondes complètement
tiens regarde toi c'est en bois et en ça
se démontre
tu vois on en fait plusieurs morceaux
comme ça et puis après on met tout ça
dans une petite boîte et c'est fini ça
seulement très pratique à porter
finalement j'ai très très fonctionnel
battant je la remets dans la boîte très
peur voyage y voilà on chante
ah oui parce que ça swingue un petit peu
plus excuse-moi contorsions de que quand
tu l'as claire huninguois en passant par
l'étape a déjà par deux amis les cannes
ça me diront les secrets de la vie et
désiste et j'ai chanté des chansons mais
comme jenny pas de baignoire
il faudra faire attention les quatre
amis sans doute encore des sont réunis
les taxes à me sont heureux car ils
aiment la vie
[Applaudissements]
megan fox a raison aujourd'hui il suffit
de vouloir devenir un ami tim suffit de
vouloir devenir sa vie
[Musique]